wealth-x has come out with a list of the
wealthiest comedians and let's show the
image to annoy me we are not on here
Andy I'm sorry here we go so Larry David
is now worth nine hundred million
dollars Jerry Seinfeld 800 billion
Letterman 390 million Cosby 360 and Adam
Sandler 290 million just to put that in
a little bit of context Larry and Jerry
both made at least 400 million this year
because of the fifth syndication
agreement for Seinfeld these guys are
rolling in dough wait listen to this
after the nine-year run that Seinfeld
had on NBC it has netted 3.1 billion
dollars in fees for reruns so that's the
stuff you get on P I accent EDS and all
that uh I'm gonna start with you on this
one Andy why are you not on the list all
on the list because I but I prefer to
keep my finances private uh no I own
four grudge I have problems with Larry
David on the way on the way the plots of
Curb Your Enthusiasm okay i think
seinfeld is up there with the gray shows
of all time and it was one of the last
shows whatever i loves raymond was
another one where if you create that
show and you produce that show you made
a lot of my son a big wedge that them
their money but bill cosby needs to
return some of that just for his people
I don't know why comics are in love with
this guy he said oh I went to see him he
was going on for three hours just cut it
down to 45 minutes the guy rambles he
sanctimonious and uh in other words I'd
like to use yeah I have to say in 1983 I
saw Bill Cosby himself on HBO and that
is what got me into doing that stand
accounts funny I don't have those I used
to love his show well now he just he
just he just sits in the stool and and
it's too much rambling and they's always
yelling people are these numbers just
crazy because comedians shouldn't
comedians be the every person that are
talking about life's problems and the
disproportionate power in the world and
fighting the power and how can these
guys do that when they're making this no
I don't think we should begrudge them
their money just because they're
supposed to make observations about the
everyman I mean it's their right to make
the money if I were Julia Louie Dreyfus
or you know any of the rest of the cast
I would probably consider making a
bleach cocktail at this
I dielman they got I know that she comes
from one of the wealthiest families and
but you know but god Bless You God go
vaya con Dios do you see grown ups to
forge I didn't point ok I saw it because
my 13 year old cousin asked me to take
her ok um and she hated it she thought
it was the greatest thing she's ever
seen that is their demographic 13 year
old girls 11 year old boys how does that
kind of movie make that man that much
money those guys gonna ever grow up
comedic Lee yeah immediately I say into
my camera yeah ok again god bless no I
don't bless Adam Sandler I say god damn
out of there he's been met I used to
love him he was on Saturday Night Live
he did the Hanukkah song and he's
cranking out then and Chris Rock Chris
Rock he did the movie because he fell in
love with the money yeah well ok so
that's that's the part I want to talk
about so some of these guys Letterman
who I still think there's any money hang
I still think that even start robbing
but I think Letterman is I have robisz
and I I don't have as many appearance
how many appearances you I don't want to
say but I think it's up to 38 I have 38
less than you so but right so Letterman
is still as edgy as he was and you and
Larry David I still love so is there
something though with somebody like
Sandler we're clearly it's just become
about the money cuz all he's doing is
turning out these things that makes ago
I think you think do good world you
really I do do you really i don't think
he's very sensitive about how about how
we are yeah and so I'm sorry Gina going
I was just like Howie Mandel also was on
the Forbes list of people who don't
deserve to be rich he was not much he
does everything okay oh it's not cuz it
bad don't forget Bobby's were the guys
on the americas got this flash bomb in
this area yeah and he's been terrible
even a terrible comedian serving the
comedy community poorly for over 40
years you could say that Adam Sandler is
the most altruistic philanthropic man in
the world because if you did see grown
ups 2 which I'm assuming I'm the only
one every every forgotten cast member
from the 90s and SNL was was given a
beautiful boy
come here i'll give him a bone my movie
horn I mean everybody was in this movie
Tim Meadows a bunch of people some
didn't even have speaking lines but he
wanted to make sure they were all taken
care of apparently yeah so should we
give him a longer leash because of that
because i really like these guys well
these guys Sandler specifically well
yeah because somebody like that where
even if he's making crappy movies and he
used to be great and doing all that
great stuff on SNL that at this point he
is helping out a group of guys that
never necessarily really flipped it to
the other one can't he be detained in
the London Airport for nine hours until
he admits that he's making crap now this
is anecdotal cuz we're not friends but
uh Steve Martin I thought said that when
he started making like Cheaper by the
Dozen 8 and 14 that he was doing that
more to finance his art collection and
hey you know he's being honest I love
Steve Martin that is an awful excuse
that's what does that make you more
likable just so i can buy fancy art
exactly i'm buying something of good
quality by doing this crap but I
appreciate that he didn't lie about it
right I appreciate that he and say but
seriously like Cheaper by the Dozen 42
check it out is it you're gonna fear
it's a life lesson but it's not and he
knows that I said that the excuse they
all make I mean I saw De Niro at one of
the awards shows he said you know I had
to make little fockers because I want to
make some good movies every now and
again well I love the Ben Stiller said
that he was something wanted to meet
Robert De Niro or something like that
and that's why the Fokker saying
wouldn't know wouldn't the dinner have
saved us all a bunch of terrible movies
one night at Jerry's deli yeah yeah well
you see Midnight Run then you see how
great de niro's I don't think I don't
believe that he should be doing although
he recently made it oh he was in that
movie David L Russell he was great in
that movie I'm not sure which one you're
talking about but he's done a couple of
these and things like you know we don't
Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence Jennifer
Lawrence M everybody yeah let's just
stuck on Midnight Run whatever happened
to Charles Grodin I like that he's the
brand he's no great he was supposed to
be in the Graduate you know he turned
you gay he turned it down but he's
unbelievably brilliant actor alright
well point is i'm pretty sure that i can
speak for all three of us were available
for some of these roles if someone yeah
oh I would be in grown-ups tree in a
second you kidding me
right now is brother